So
all right,
so Sarah dies.
Abraham makes a bargain with the
hittites to purchase a burial place for her and they offer it as a gift and he
insists upon paying for it.
It's a little story that basically indicates two things that Abraham was the
kind of guy that you trust pretty much when you see him and that even if
something is offered to them as a gift,
he's going to do everything to be reciprocal about it.
And so it's not a massively important part of the story,
but it's in keeping with the same narrative flow.
And so if Ron,
who's a hittite,
offers a burial place as a gift and Abraham says,
no,
you know,
you have to let me pay for it,
and everyone says he will.
And that works out very well.
And so he has a good burrito place for his wife.
And then
Abraham decides that Isaac needs a wife.
And so he sends his eldest servant to miss a potassium.
You have to find a wife for Isaac.
And
there's this strange ritual that's performed.
So it says in the story that the servant places his hand under Abraham's thigh
to,
to swear,
but that isn't really what it means.
It means that he places his hand don't know exactly how to say this properly.
Well,
use your imagination.
How about that?
And the idea is that as far as I can tell that he's swearing on the future,
he swearing on future people.
It's something like that.
So that,
that sort of what testified means,
right?
Think about the route while I'm not kidding,
I'm not kidding.
That is what that is the derivation,
right?
If it is the derivation.
So,
so,
uh,
so anyways,
this is a serious issue.
And so that servant has to go and find Isaac,
a good wife and he wants him to find Isaac,
a wife who is willing to accept the same fundamental belief system,
which is something like the belief in a God that's a unity rather than a
plurality.
You know,
the other thing that young was very insistent upon was that there was a
relationship between
polytheism and psychological confusion and monotheism and psychological
unification.
I really liked that idea too,
that you know that that what you're trying to do,
because you are a plurality,
that that's one of the things the psychoanalysts were really good at figuring
out that the cognitive scientists haven't touched yet as far as I can tell
they're way behind the psychoanalysts and that element of thinking is that you
are composed of sub personalities which all have their own desires and their own
viewpoint,
their own thoughts and their own perceptions and they're in a war with each
other constantly,
maybe even a Darwinian war.
It's been.
It's been portrayed that way by certain neuroscientists and that that one of the
goals of life is to integrate all of that plurality into a hierarchical ethical
structure that has some canonical ethic at the pinnacle.
Right.
We've talked a little bit about that and it's not obvious what should be at the
pinnacle,
but we can guess at it.
It's.
It's that which we admire.
That's one way of thinking about it.
It's that that describes fairplay across a sequence of games.
That's another good way of thinking about it.
It's.
It's the heroic ideal.
That's another way of thinking about it,
but it's combined with generosity,
you know,
because the hero,
the mythological hero goes out into the unknown and slays the dragon and gets
the gold,
but then it comes back to the community and distributes what's found.
And so it's courage plus generosity and um,
and so all of your,
all of that interior struggling that you're doing is an attempt to bang yourself
against the world with challenge constantly to hit everything together.
Like you're beating on a piece of iron to,
to,
to cure it,
let's say,
so that you don't,
you're not an internal contradiction.
You're not massive competing God,
something like that because it's just too psychologically stressful and hard on
everyone else and impossible for them to get along with you,
with your one thing,
one moment and another thing,
another moment.
And so.
So anyways,
Abraham insists that Isaac find a wife from among people who are likely to carry
off forward the monotheistic tradition.
And I'm not sure that the monotheistic tradition is actually indistinguishable,
is actually distinguishable from the individualistic tradition.
I think they might be the same thing at different levels of analysis,
you know,
so because the individual means and divided in some sense,
right?
To be an individual means to be one thing and the other thing that mitigates
against the idea of life is happiness is it isn't obvious to me that it's
happiness.
That is what molds you and shapes you.
You know,
it's something more like optimal challenge voluntarily undertaken.
It's something like that.
Right?
And I think that's echoed in the idea that everyone has a moral obligation to
raise their cross,
something like that,
to accept the fact of their mortality voluntarily.
I believe that that's the case and I do actually think that that's a
prerequisite to proper psychological development because if you're not willing
to take your mortality on voluntarily,
like if you're kicking and fighting about it constantly and you have every
reason to don't get me wrong,
then you can't act forthrightly in the world.
Right?
You're going to be afraid and when you're afraid,
then you can't voluntarily take on a.
and then if you can't take voluntarily take on a challenge,
then you can't develop.
And so again,
the life seems to be something like if it's a proper life,
is the voluntarily voluntary taking on of great challenges and maybe that's
better than happiness.
I can certainly more noble,
you know,
it's not a word we use very much anymore.
The idea of nobility because we're so obsessed with happiness.
But I think happiness is a,
like if it comes along,
man,
great,
you know,
wonderful.
Don't,
don't take it lightly or for granted because it's fleeting.
But the idea that that's what you should be for in some sense to seems to me if,
if that's what life is for than maybe it shouldn't be.
Maybe that's correct because that isn't what life is,
but it also doesn't.
It isn't obvious to me that that's what life should be,
you know?
I mean,
if you really love someone like,
like your son,
let's say,
would you say,
well I hope he has a happy life,
or would you say,
I hope he accomplishes great things.
It seems to me that that's better than the accomplishing of great things.
And because that's admirable,
you know,
it's like a happy person is a happy person,
but a noble person has an admirable person and,
and that's,
that's better man.
And so maybe there are better things than happiness.
And so you can't judge being on the basis of the ratio of suffering to pleasure,
something like that.
It's.
And I don't think we do that.
I don't believe we do that.